the Italian government has put about 1/4
of its population under quarantine in a
bid to stop a rapidly expanding outbreak
of the corona virus Prime Minister
Giuseppe Conte signed a decree after
midnight now the lockdown affects the
region of Lombardy and other northern
provinces and includes Venice and
Italy's financial capital Milan Italy is
the country with the most coronavirus
infections in Europe the government's
most recent figures show some five
thousand eight hundred and eighty-three
confirmed cases and 233 people have died
of the disease the lockdown is the most
drastic measure yet taken in a European
country to try to contain the virus
deserted train stations and empty roads
northern Italian cities now placed under
quarantine wake up to the effects of the
new decree overnight a very different
scene news of the imminent lockdown set
off a rush to beat the clock in Milan
and in other areas affected by the
lockdown people raised to train stations
trying to get out before it's too late
I read two hours ago that they may be
putting out an urgent decree putting
Padua in the red zone and because I'd
like to return down south to my
relatives I decided to go earlier
Lombardi is Italy's most populous region
with ten million inhabitants its capital
Milan is Italy's financial heart it
attracts professionals and students from
around the world and from all parts of
Italy this is where the coronavirus has
hit the hardest
living hospitals unable to cope with a
growing number of cases Italian
authorities say the drastic measures to
curb the outbreak could not wait any
longer the party the Lombardi R Delta
provincial Lombardi and for the other
northern regions that I have listed
there will be a band for everybody to
move in or out of these territories also
within the same territory
jeezum Oh Vera Queen D exceptions will
be allowed only for proven professional
needs special cases and for health
issues dissolute a has the regions
affected prepare to implement the decree
northern Italians get ready to see their
lifestyle change drastically at least
for a few weeks those who do not respect
the measures could face jail terms and
fines businesses are also growing more
and more concerned among others the
virus is already taking a toll on
Italy's tourism sector Easter one of the
peak times is about a month away and
reports are that as many as 90 percent
of visitors have canceled their trips
for a broader picture from the Italian
capital we're now joined by
correspondent Philip Wilin who's in Rome
hello to you Philip now do we know why
Italy has so many coronavirus cases
compared to other European countries
this one is that Italy began testing in
large numbers very early on and
scrupulous leave reported the results of
the tests and this has possibly not been
done in other European countries another
reason why they've been a large number
of fatalities is that Italy has a large
elderly population like the second
oldest population in the world after
Japan and of course it's a very popular
tourist destination so it had a lot of
dealings with China both Chinese
tourists coming to the country and of
course trade connections to Asia and to
China in particular now Philip the
strict quarantine measures that were
announced overnight Center on northern
Italy which powers the country's entire
economy so what is the government
planning to do to lessen the economic
impact of the coronavirus
well I think this is going to be a major
challenge for Italy the government has
announced a package of 7.5 billion euros
to support the economy to support
businesses and individuals whose
livelihood to be affected the opposition
says this is not nearly enough and
clearly if the most productive region of
the country and tourism effectively are
grinding to a halt one can foresee
enormous losses for the country are very
difficult to make that up until you
tally will be looking for support and
understanding from you from Europe and
won't want to be constrained by European
rules on the deficit well we're hearing
that even the Vatican has been affected
and that Pope Francis is resorting to
some unusual measures tell us more
that's right actually as we speak
the Pope will be leading Angelus prayers
but not from his window overlooking st.
Peter's Square as normally it happens
but leading the prayers by a video live
streamed on internet and visible on
television and the idea is to discourage
the faithful from gathering in large
numbers in st. Peter's Square because
obviously that could be an opportunity
for the exchange of germs and exchange
of this virus all right Philip willen
reporting from Rome we appreciate it
all right let's get the latest now from
journalist Silvia Bacardi she joins us
from the city of Milan which means that
she herself is now under lockdown hello
to you Silvia
so tell us what was it like waking up to
the news that now you are quarantined
well it was quite weird to be honest and
the feeling is a bit claustrophobic but
we
I've expected it because last night
there was a there was a draft of the the
of a decree that was leaked from the
government so we knew this was gonna
happen today
now our most people in the affective
areas supportive of these very strict
measures well the feeling is ambivalent
there are some people who actually
support what the government is doing
because they understand that this is the
only way to contain the epidemic but
there are also scared people of course
last night the major stations of Milan
were assaulted by people that wanted to
leave and to maybe get to their families
that they're living away from from
Lombardy so it's an ambivalent feeling
now give us a sense of how exactly daily
life is going to change under these
restrictions well for instance today's
Sunday and the roads are quiet empty
they're not people there are not that
many people walking around and we will
not be able to go to restaurants at
night to have drinks at night we won't
be able to go to the movie today we
won't be able to go to the theatre
tonight it's a it's a very weird feeling
me and my friends are trying to
understand if it's okay to you know meet
up for dinner or not it's a weird
feeling I would say well what about
things like food or other essential
goods are authorities ensuring that
deliveries will continue despite this
lockdown well there has not been
ordinance yet about this but they they
were saying today yesterday that they
might close supermarkets at weekends we
can see what happened in the previous
red zones mmm supermarkets were
assaulted at the beginning literally
assaulted people will just go and grab
whatever they could take and then the
next few days they just calm down they
closed the supermarket and then after a
while they just reopen it and everything
went back to
I think this is exactly what's happening
today this morning so there are many
supermarkets that around my area have
been you know assaulted by people trying
to get whatever they can but I think
things will come down and big
supermarkets chain will be able to get
into the right zone and bringing you
know food supplies and basic needs
supplies
all right journalist Silvia Bacardi
reporting from Milan which is now in
lockdown we thank you so much for
talking to us thank you